the omicron variant causing a big spike
in cases hospitals throughout the state
are struggling to keep up with staffing
demands a nevada hospital association
report explains staffing levels are at a
critical stage joe muller spoke to some
hospital staff about what is actually
going on he's live outside sunrise
hospital with more joe
christian we have seen the long lines of
cars with people trying to get tested
for coven 19. meantime hospitals like
sunrise here are dealing with a spike in
patients a new report shows just how
impacted hospitals are
it's spreading like
wildfire mountain view hospital nurse
nicole taylor says times are getting
tough nurses are calling out sick at an
astronomical rate that leaves the nurses
who aren't sick
to essentially pick up the slack an
update from the nevada hospital
association this week shows staffing
remains at crisis levels at hospitals
throughout the valley a representative
from mountain view sunrise and southern
hills hospitals tells me they have all
seen an increase of 105 percent over the
last two weeks in copen 19 patients
nurses and health care workers are
feeling
exhausted i also spoke to stephen murta
the chief medical officer from sunrise
hospital and medical center we too are
feeling the same
staffing challenges he says they are
making staffing adjustments to make sure
they can take care of patients they are
utilizing the nurse and then
and bringing on a cna which is a
certified nursing assistant
or a patient care technician and have
them work in teams so that they that one
nurse can manage more murder and many
others say people are showing up to
hospitals looking for copin 19 tests and
that is putting a strain on operations
er is here for you in an acute care
emergency but if you have minor
illnesses or you're looking for a
testing site please go to the southern
nevada health district
national nurses united plans to hold a
demonstration shedding the light on the
snapping problems nationwide here
locally they plan to hold a
demonstration tomorrow at 8 a.m outside
of mountain view hospital reporting live
joe muller live local now
joe thank you for that well in regards
to tomorrow's demonstration a
representative from mountain view tells
us no one cares more for our colleagues
than they do they say it is
disappointing that the labor union
leadership doesn't recognize the
valuable contributions of all colleagues
who are working to help patients